thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
currently filling with audio that's
awesome uh I had a little problem we
fixed it what an idea troubleshooting is
awesome so today we are talking about
what are some Kinks you have always
wanted to try
interesting go ahead Nick
take it away probably in my younger
years
well actually we did try it and it was
just like um
no 69ing dude
you are a vanilla [__] that is
your king do that every day dude I was
joking I was totally joking obviously
nah man I was totally joking and I'm way
more such a sick joke
hardcore than that I've even done 69
standing up girl holding eye yeah
[Laughter]
is maybe the most overrated position I
think it is yeah I think it's fun for a
good like 12 seconds though look if I
had a blast you know what it's fun in a
new relationship oh yeah everything is
if you are so very very lucky to have
one putting your dick in her mouth and
you can't see it yeah what's the [__]
what's the point sometimes it's too
intense to see it and I come too fast
what's the point I get it what's the
point that's why that's the point I
gotta close my eyes is that we see your
face moving around what if you have a
nest cam down there
you get the feeling and the show the
show the show's unfortunate yeah but
sometimes [__] in the face is is a show
sometimes a close-up of the [__] is a
show too well yeah but that was a
gynecologist
nice Pooch right a college hey you know
what I would want sounds like you guys
are gay you don't like [__] wait no no
no that's all we said wait we didn't say
that hold on damn it ah we're gay you
guys are so gay compared to me I want to
try the thing where it's VR but you're
getting the actual thing in real life at
the same time with the same person yeah
I've done a Sharper Image the same
person that's strong but okay
you're having sex with isn't as hot as
the one in VR right and is that
considered cheating
I mean I guess it would be cheating if
you told the person that your partner
during the experience that she was also
in VR yeah I swear to the god baby that
it's I swear it's you in there I'll
never worked dude that'll never works
definitely not hold on babe I gotta
you're like I got a question why don't
you just want to take off the headset
that'd see me do it I'm doing it right
right now baby I love it I love you but
I gotta do this right it's like um and
then you're playing [__] lightsaber
and [__] beat saber beat saber because
the VR version of you is hotter
oh that's not bad that's not bad if you
just explain that yeah and they should
be she would not be insecure at all and
she'd want to do it and then everything
would be it kind of be like a toy like
it doesn't I know that's not you but
it's just to see the if the sensation
matches up or is heightened
okay yeah could be cool
uh could be cool Joe
oh I got a lot you have the floor I want
to see
um
lesbian orgy accent action while I eat
potassium pistachios okay how about we
do an underrated or overrated list of
all the Kinks that you guys how about
yeah you go and then we'll just get back
to this yeah
uh kissing with your eyes open that's
underrated underrated dude you like keep
your eyes open dude okay dude you're gay
no I'm not kissing I'm not kissing a guy
okay okay okay is that gay dude
how long huh how are you staring the
whole time dude is it like tantric
staring
yeah but the hard part is really creepy
your eyes are going in what about sex
with sunglasses on that's underrated
both both people there is a flaw gotta
make me come too fast the flaw is this
is too cool
you're gonna bang glasses the whole time
the whole time the frames are
appropriate size okay here's here's a
serious question when it comes things
like Kinks right how do you know that
that's your Kink if you don't explore a
bunch of Kinks to find out if that's
because I got my ass
[Music]
but yes please continue
to tell that 18 times no no but no one
knows how I developed it no one knows
why are you kidding what's the origin
you're keeping it a secret orange story
orange
yeah
the girlfriend now is with at the time
well no actually I was a girl no no
the first time
the first time it was proposed to me I
was like oh girl that's kind of gay I
don't want that yeah I told her no I
said no because like she was like here
let me try to lick your ass and I was
like oh no like that's gross right let
me get a little paste so fast forward we
break up and I'm like you know what were
that no no no no no no no no no just no
because she's gay yeah so she broke up
with him no but I feel like
you know like when you kind of
reevaluate the relationship you go you
know what I should have just tried it
she was real uh okay why was I such a
prude it was cool like yeah she wanted
to just she was like you might like it
and then Saul's like well that's
probably past you know I'm in my next
relationship
and then so uh she goes lower and lower
and then she goes like past the ball and
I was like whoa and I busted really
quick and she goes oh you like that she
hasn't quite gone to the butthole yet
yeah
she dude it was like it was like a
[__] nuclear eject button I I imagine
Joe's like this and his legs go like
yeah like that all right your legs go up
no she did like one little ball lick the
underneath the in between the butthole
and the ball the gooch the gooch she did
one little lick and I [__] shot like
a [__] Apollo 11. yeah yeah Apollo
Creed they just spilled a load of plates
and I was like ah I can't take it
anymore right oh and she goes oh you
like that and then so I guess it was
like a tease kind of thing where like
afterwards like like I was like no it's
too much it's too intense I can't take
it you know and I didn't like busting
fast because I was like I don't get to
have sex but she thought it was so funny
so then I was always like
oh kind of like
used and abused yeah yeah I was like
that's two intense and then she thought
she the reaction was funny and then
afterwards I was like you know what it's
pretty nice yeah I like that and I
developed it because of it okay I didn't
even know it was a thing yeah oh you
haven't seen it yet around the world it
was done to me then I was like
oh give me that crack yeah yeah
and then I'll date every chick who wants
to eat butt in the whole world huh
bro like Joe kind of from the future
girls go nasty why are you gonna say it
like that take it away
really nasty or at least the girls at
Joe dates I think girls are hornier than
guys
yeah I'm not okay I mean I think to each
their own I'm just kidding I don't know
I just say that to myself all right but
like let's get it real quick all right
check this out okay be gay you gay I'm
gonna get gay real quick okay all right
call me again but say it sexier yeah
okay gay yeah
all right so have you guys heard that
the rumor I don't know again I don't
know if it's true but we're gonna get
gay real quick the male orgasms of the
prostate yeah exactly the prostate
orgasm right and and apparently it's a
[__] amazing orgasm right but the
thing is unless you're willing to shove
something up your [__] to get to the
prostate you'll never know he is you'll
never know that's too far someone tried
to enter the gates and I it killed it
from forbidden fruit yeah but that's
what I'm saying like how would we know
that we would like it unless we do you
know it so are you trying to I don't
know but like is it gay if I'm like
maybe I should find out yeah what if you
like it so much that you turn games
that's okay that's the fear right oh man
yeah yeah because now you now you're
marrying a guy at a courthouse and
suddenly I'm adopting kids I'm telling
you but if the flag of your house if I
gotta take the census if it's a female's
finger
is that still gay yeah but is it what if
that's the Gateway right what if it's a
female's finger and you're like that's
not gay and then and then you're like
can you do two fingers I need something
thicker and rounder Adventure it's like
hey I'd rather just have a dick I need
Man Hands have you ever had a like a gay
friend really sit you down and be like
bro trust me it is like nothing you've
ever felt closest I've ever had to it is
Bart telling me that he for sure can
[__] suck a dick better than the
chicken that's not the same that's not
the same dude
experience I gotta trans I have the
transgender in the DMV friends actually
tell me straight up like bro just try it
you'll never go back is that situation
them offered to blow you or are they
just talking in general about no both
probably yeah they're like if it's not
with me just do it this is fair I saw
this earlier I swear to God if I cook
one time that doesn't make me a chef
that's true well you need some practice
you need something you get a blow job
from dude one time
doesn't mean I'm gay yeah I mean I think
you're selling you're sure [__] not a
chef hahaha
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's good oh so let's uh let's get gay
so is that something that you're willing
to do so you're curious about having a
man perform a [__] no I understand
you though I wish I could know it
without knowing why I know it exactly
Colleen's like why does it have to be a
man yeah I mean like if you want to like
explore butthole stuff
no no guaranteed 100 but again to
Steve's logic which is totally sound
immediately you turn gay afterwards just
because yeah you got to go down the
rabbit hole and then you gotta vote
games yeah you gotta donate gay
food you gotta donate your gay ass bone
marrow you gotta get a Prius or a Subaru
yeah no I I get it I get the feeling of
like it's like all these gay guys are in
on this amazing secret and they want you
to know yeah but you don't want to know
if the male Gooch but think about it
that's why they're throwing parades and
Flying Flags and [__] is the male G-spot
so like everybody gotta do this [__]
yeah you guys hear me out that's why
it's called Pride you know what I mean
oh my God that's so annoying how much
they're [__] proud of this [__] I
mean that's what we're afraid of they're
like oh my God you got to get blown by a
[__] dude if only four people do oh
everybody
today's video is brought to you by Warby
Parker okay so sometimes you're on a
website looking and shopping for eyewear
and you're like man this stuff looks so
cool but I don't know if it's gonna look
good on me so pass how many of you guys
do that at home because for me there's
been so many times when I've bought
glasses it came in and I'm looking at it
I put it on and for some reason it just
does not fit but thank goodness we got
Warby Parker baby yeah cause they got
the home try on kit where you can pick
five of the glasses you can try it on
and then you can send back the ones that
you don't want and what I like about
Warby Parker is sometimes you're a lot
of times you're buying stuff for a
special event someone's wedding you're
gonna go over here and it's too late if
you get the glasses and it doesn't fit
your outfit or your needs oh yeah so
with Warby Parker you deal with
sunglasses eyeglasses they got all kinds
even contact lenses for Eye Care kit and
they even have in-person retail stores
too all right so like I was saying Warby
Parker offers you everything you need
for happier ice eyeglasses sunglasses
contact lenses and even eye exams and
you can shop with them online or in
stores too and glasses start at 95 bucks
including prescription lenses so try the
Warby Parker's free home try on program
order five pairs of glasses to try on at
home for free there's no obligation to
buy ships free and even includes a
prepaid shipping label so try five pairs
of glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com off the Record a trans a
trans gender dude hit me up in the DMS
and said exactly that as a as a
proposition they're like are you sure
you don't want to like blow job from me
like I have one I know that it can feel
good and I'm like as flattering and as
tempting as that sounds
no thank you but then but then it is
like I'll lick your [__] and you're
like that's all they could have got
it's the lack of the visual of a woman
with my penis in her mouth is gonna just
crush it yeah I'm gonna Crush my little
boner yeah my little bummer's gonna
frickle her way yeah so the stubble's
gonna ruin it for you you know 100 but
we're talking about what we want that's
not a kink what we need is that old
school like a Pepsi and Coke test yeah
the Pepsi challenge exactly yeah
right and you're just like which one's
better yeah a little bit but dude if
they're filming it and then afterwards
going on the tubes like I think we all
be sweating like oh my God I hope I
picked the chick yeah yeah I busted so
hard I hope I won't hoping to pick the
chick though I don't know because it's
gonna ruin me because it goes on YouTube
and YouTube's like you guys need to stop
uploading porn please thank you
but no no none of these are Kinks though
all right what about things like media
what about when you when you get
punished
never done it I'm listening oh okay all
right BDSM you've never done one never
never done yeah no never done one of
them like [__] getting punished and
[__] getting tied up and like getting
whipped or anything it doesn't it
doesn't feel like it would turn me on or
or be something I'm into we'll get
spanked Anthony what if the guy had a
whip the guy why is it a guy we still
staying again
help me with the whip
it's like water girl why is it the
homies look at me boy or girl this is
like an Indiana Jones whip
the homies take turns yeah you know I
mean you know like I'm I'm thinking that
scene from Mr and Mrs Smith I'm thinking
what Angelina Jolie which is about to
murder this dude but she comes in with
this [__] hot as [__] like yeah you
said I like the outfit I don't want her
to beat me up though but I've never been
I was in a situation here we go and I
really feel kind of story for everything
bro he's he's a man that's after like
800 pistachio nuts over here part of
this King he told us that well I wanna I
wanna sit here and go right now and two
hot lesbian girls kissing that's the
thing you like I want to watch
but you see because I feel like I need
to do something so it's like I want to
pick out something like it's a show
because if I'm masturbating while
watching them it's kind of awkward it's
creepy yeah so
um I always wondered like well girls
like rough stuff right but then this
level of rough was like
what the [__] is this and this is when I
realized that I can't do aggressive
stuff in bed
because I think it's tied to
um
um getting beat up by my parents so like
when I and then also associating
violence with fighting and then so like
for her
she just she uh we were just making out
passionately and she she looks at my
face and she goes Wham and smacks me as
[__] hard as she could why'd you cut
my piano strings
and I never had that from a girl
um and at that point I give her a
[__] slap back in the face she wanted
it harder oh gave her that [__]
smacked her on a on the butt and as I
was kissing her I was like now I just
want to beat you up
and I'm like that's way this is not this
is
really healthy I was like this is not
what I was supposed to feel like right
but also like in that situation they're
kind of supposed to tell you that they
like that type you'd have a safe word no
she just went for it oh and there was
another time when no no no so after
after we made out and then like and then
we did that like it took me so out of it
so it took me so out of it and then like
even we were doing she would slap me in
the face hit me [__] punch me right
and then later I'm all like I'm all like
she was an aggressive girl is she
dressed like a hockey goalie
she's gonna she dressed like Ronda
Rousey
it's crazy dude so afterwards
I was like
you know what I I don't think I like
that like I think it's weird
and then she's like yeah it's just so
hot like my hand just slips and I'm all
like that sounds so wrong but whatever
she has an extra thing yeah I like this
girl I'm not gonna lie yeah so then um
it's kind of cool she seems like Israeli
Special Forces yeah yeah oh bro she was
Eastern European so very aggressive but
anyways
um so so uh I was eating her out one
time and then I went up for air and when
my face went up for air
she went she went that's so hot
bam and smack me in the [__] face
right
so around when you're like
impulsive is what
is what did she seems pretty cool bro I
[__] snap I just yelled at her I was
like you know what though I told you
[__] God damn yeah and then
and then so I was like hold on why why
am I having these reactions that's when
I had to think about it like yo I don't
I don't think I connect being hit the
same way as you it's not like a form of
like rough passionate because she's like
oh I can't even imagine like
feeling that way violently I think it's
like rough play so I'm like nah for me
like for me it just puts me in a bad
mental space like I I wanted to start
pounding your face and I never felt that
in the metal middle of sex ever before
it's taking me to a dangerous space
where like I just want to like kill your
ass and she goes I could never even see
you like that I can't do that to you so
then I was like yeah I don't think it's
gonna [__] work man their desired
outcome that she was looking for when
she smashed you did she want you to
react a certain way like what was I
think she wanted to be hit too but it's
like
some sort of psychological situation I
think it's like BDSM play like I think
you're going through that world but I
also think like
it's so we were both experimenting in
like we were just passionate at the time
right she she told me she never really
had a history of that and me too I never
tried it before but it just a lot of
things were just coming out when you're
just like high energy for sure dude
right and then like I didn't even know
that about myself until after that and
I'm like I don't think I could do this
whole whipping and and and and and
bondage and I don't think that for me
just put me in the bed and and let's
just let's just do missionary sex let's
do old-fashioned can we be soft and
passionate you know what I mean like but
now but now you know that's that's the
important part yeah so that's like a
unique lesson for me is like I I don't
think I can do like rough stuff like
that right yeah here's another Kink that
I've always been kind of curious about
but I have no idea if I would really
really like it yeah uh like sex in like
a public place and I'm talking about
like like eyes on you
oh like a like a swingers party you kind
of like it I don't I have no idea if I
would even be able to perform like Nina
get get away I can't see Anthony yeah
well you're you're covering him I'm just
yelling at her I didn't even show up
this is the one time he shows up what
the [__] dude are you kidding me you
want to go you tell me I want to show to
watch this guy have sex and then
suddenly you're like whoa this really is
a different type of turn on or what have
you tried and you're like [__] I can't
even get it up you know what I mean I
have no idea is the um which one do you
like better the one where you're being
seen and you're not supposed to be or
where you're being seen and everyone's
in on it
I don't know if I can go where like
everybody's supposed to be watching me
I'm not gonna bump into you oh because
doesn't it turn a little like
performative right yeah yeah I don't
know you are a performer though that's
like that's like maybe two degrees too
far I think the closest I would be able
to go is like having sex in a public
place where you're obviously not
supposed to be having sex and like like
the possibility of getting caught I
think I could go there yeah but what if
you get caught and become a sex offender
because of indecent exposure that sucks
I mean who's watching you you sicko yeah
we're just talking hypothetically you
[__] fart would you would you live
stream it
I want to get caught by a by by a cute
sexy security guard and she goes oh I'm
horny too and I'm like you can join I'll
tell you guys a story I've never I'll
tell you the story I've never told
before never told it one time all right
on anywhere not even on my podcast or
anything nice
um so there there was a time where I was
with the I was with the girlfriend we
were like you know she had a friend over
right and her friend uh like I hadn't
seen my girlfriend in a while
and I definitely was like just wanting
to [__] my girlfriend but then her
friend was over and like me and my
girlfriend were kind of getting like a
little frisky and [__] and then the
friend like came in the room
like and she was like down to just watch
some [__] because we had just went to a
strip club and so like that mood was
already like everyone's like in like
[__] Vibes were everywhere it was
elevated right elevated exactly and so
then I like there was a moment where
like I had a like I I had a boner and
[__] right and the friend could see the
boner and she's like staring at the
boner and my chick was like doing stuff
over the pants to the boner and then the
chick is like can I watch you guys [__]
and then I chickened out whoa what was
your was the girl down the girl that you
were with down the girl that I was with
said it was up to me but how did you
chicken out were you just like it was
like as I feel like if I say yeah did
you spin it into a joke or something you
also feel like it was a trap I felt like
it was a trap I was like I was like I'm
gonna fail the test and then I'm going
down
should have doubled down and been like
hey like if anything
watching is weird but if we all just do
it together it's less weird right that's
how you fail the test the idiot this is
not a trap you gotta double down with
confidence the no win scenario he
doesn't know yet he doesn't know yet
right there I guarantee you it's gonna
work it's not the sex that is not a sex
hat removed that is how you blow up the
[__] simulator yeah guaranteed it
works you're telling me with glasses
like that this guy can't pull that off
I'm telling you right now if I was like
hey I don't know if you can watch but
you can [__] me too
I am a guilty Catholic boy yeah but I
will never forget the way that that
chick was looking at my boner I was like
oh [__] like it's on you never you
didn't go why are you making me choose
why don't you two do and I'll watch
I wish that Joe was my friend back then
I didn't know him yet call him up former
friend you know you know too much
pressure